pour elle c'est un honneur de fouler le
sable de la Ravine Blanche zillie
artiste engagé de Mayotte à hâte de
partager sa musique ma première fois mon
premier choix à la Réunion à
Saint-Pierre la ville où vu les
statistiques où je suis vraiment écouté
c'est vraiment un rêve qui se réalise et
c'est un plaisir d'être là Zili a
commencé à fredonner les champs
traditionnels dès l'âge de 7 ans avec sa
mère et sa grand-mère aujourd'hui elle
propose une musique personnelle qu'elle
a mixé entre tradition et modernité
c'est de l'afro ou Gojo
urbain j'appelle ça comme ça parce que
je suis je touche un peu à tout à
l'aphrobite
à l'urbain et aussi en Gojo qui est la
danse traditionnelle de Mayotte
ce soir sur la scène de la poudrière
elle prépare un show coloré et rythmique
alors je vais essayer de proposer ce que
j'ai l'habitude de proposer de l'énergie
de l'amour de la musique et tout
simplement un spectacle à l'asili
[Musique]